[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEORGI KHOMERIKI: Just to give
you a quick idea of the scale
that we operate on at
Walmart, I'm sure many of you
have heard about
the company Walmart.
So Walmart employs around
2.3 million associates.
And we serve around 270 million
customers on a weekly basis.
And we do this through over
11,000 stores that we have
and various e-commerce systems.
And all of this is
operating in 28 countries.
So you can imagine
that even when
we're kind of
planning to roll out
some internal application
that is supposed
to cater our own
internal associates,
we're already having to deal
with considerable scale.
So that's quite interesting
from a platform perspective,
especially.
And the other thing that's
also very interesting
is the fact that Walmart has two
different kind of landscapes.
One is these large
scale clusters
that we were operating
in the cloud.
And then we also have many kind
of smaller edge clusters that
are all operating in our stores
and our distribution centers.
So again, for a
platform engineer,
this is quite interesting.
Now, I'm sure you're
not here to listen
to me talk about how awesome
engineering at Walmart is.
So let's just dive
into the actual theme
of this presentation.
So once upon a time, there was
a monolith, perhaps multiple.
And of course, this monolith
was beautifully architected.
It made our life so great and
fulfilled so many business
values.
And of course, my
slides, by the way,
are an oversimplification
of orders of magnitude.
But essentially this
monolith was very modular
with various modules
inside of this thing.
And these modules
would essentially
communicate with
each other to fulfill
whatever responsibilities
they had.
And you know, the
invocation between modules
was some form of in-memory
invocation function calls
or method calls.
And you know,
generally this actually
brought us a pretty long
way, until, of course,
a certain threshold was
breached and we woke up one day
and we realized, well,
the size of the code base,
the complexity of the overall
system, the scalability
challenges that we're
facing, and in general
the whole development velocity
is definitely not where it's
supposed to be anymore.
And so we did the obvious thing.
And at the time,
we referred to it
as introducing a
service-oriented architecture.
Today we kind of
talk about it as--
or refer to it as a
microservices architecture.
We broke up the monolith
and decomposed it
into individual services.
So in a simplified
sense, essentially, we
took all of those modules and
made them individual services.
And with these
individual services,
we're able to kind of develop
them individually, scale them
individually, and
maintain them better.
Of course, we had to change
our whole engineering culture
at the company.
But life was much better
now, and velocity came back.
However, of course, by solving
the kind of old set of problems
that we had with the
monolith, now all of a sudden
we had a brand new
set of challenges
that we had to solve with
this new architecture.
One of the things
is, for example,
the act of you know
servicing vocation is
all of a sudden very
different, like these arrows
in between the services
become much more
critical and important and
we have to very much focus on
them, whereas in a monolith,
you know, when a module invokes
another module,
essentially it's usually
a simple matter of
preparing a stack
and having the CPU jump to
a particular instruction.
Now all of a sudden we need to
actually traverse the network.
And this is something,
obviously, that can fill often.
And so we need some
type of resiliency.
Also, how do all of these
services discover each other?
Like, how does A know
where to find service B?
And if service B kind of
changes its whereabouts,
how does service A
get notified of that?
And how do we even observe this
overall kind of large system?
How do we know what's going
on at any point in time
with our kind of
larger infrastructure?
And debugging, how do
we even debug and trace
kind of problems?
How do we pinpoint
the particular source
of any problem that we're
facing in production?
And of course, you know,
orchestration, you know,
now that we're kind of invoking
services via remote calls,
somehow we need some
type of governance
where everything is
done appropriately
and we need some type
of policy enforcement.
So we have all of
these new challenges.
And again, we were
quite early to this.
And the first solution to
this new set of challenges
was to kind of
introduce some type
of centralized intermediary.
And you can think of
an enterprise service
bus or some type of
API gateway of sorts.
And the idea was pretty simple.
Essentially, instead of
having all of the services
directly talk to each other
and instantiate point to point
connections, now what they
do is they kind of talk
through this centralized
intermediary.
And it would take care of things
like discovery and routing
and resiliency and policy
enforcement and observability
and you name it.
It was all there to
a certain extent.
And that certainly
solved the problems
that we had when
we kind of naively
decomposed our monolith into
individual microservices.
But of course, once again,
having solved the current set
of problems, we
have now introduced
a brand new set of problems.
With this particular
architecture,
some of the most
important things
is the fact that
we've introduced
a single point of failure.
Since everyone-- all of the
services are relying on this
kind of centralized broker
or intermediary of sorts
to communicate with each other--
if this thing goes
down, obviously no one
can communicate with each
other, and we have a problem.
In addition, we
also introduced kind
of a different form of
scalability challenges,
because as our microservices
architecture is growing--
and of course at Walmart, we
went from dozens to hundreds
to thousands of services now--
this centralized
kind of system has
to account for the
additional load
and throughput and
overall weight that
is put on the system.
So we as a platform team have
to constantly maintain, monitor
this thing and kind
of keep scaling it up
as the usage of it grows.
Of course, the latency
story isn't all that
great either here,
because when we decompose
the monolith, of course, and we
introduce remote invocations,
all of a sudden our
latencies went in memory
to kind of remote calls
that kind of deteriorated
the kind of performance
with orders of magnitude.
Now all of a sudden we're
actually doing multiple
hops on a network, which is
definitely not a great thing
for performance overall.
And from a kind of
platform perspective,
as we're trying to kind
of innovate and improve
the overall kind of platform,
whenever we're looking
to kind of make changes
or add new features
or even fix bugs
at runtime, we have
to be very careful
because any change we
do in this kind of
centralized system
is impacting all of the
tenants at the same time.
So that is kind of very tricky.
And at some point, the
velocity of our improvements
comes to a grinding
halt. And so we obviously
recognize that the fact that
these problems that we're now
facing are due to
the fact that we
have this kind of
centralized nature.
Our solution has
been centralized.
And that's kind of the culprit
of these particular problems.
So the obvious kind
of next step is
to take that centralized
solution and decentralize it.
So at the time, the thing
that we came up with
was to create a--
let's call it a
microservices framework
of sorts, essentially like a
framework or set of libraries,
that take care of all
of the same concerns
that the centralized system was
doing, the same kind of routing
and discovery and resiliency,
et cetera, et cetera.
And you know, thereby
we would kind of
have this framework take care
of all of those requirements
and we would eliminate the need
of this centralized system.
Now, this certainly
kind of solved
all of those problems we
had at that point in time.
But once again, we've kind
of changed architecture
and we went from an old set of
problems and now all of sudden
we have a brand new set
of problems once again.
The problems that we're
facing now, for example,
is the fact that this particular
solution is non polyglot.
Now, in the case of Walmart,
our engineering teams
are free to use whatever
technology they would like
to use and that they feel is the
best fit for their kind of use
cases.
So you will find any
language, any framework,
any set of libraries being
utilized in our company.
And we as a platform
team somehow
have to facilitate these
kind of platform concerns
for all of these
technology stacks, which,
in this particular architecture,
essentially boils down
to us having to kind of port
this microservices framework
to all of the different
technology stacks, which
is definitely quite the
overhead on our team.
In addition, the actual kind
of microservices framework
now is all of the sudden
hardcoded into the application.
So your platform is now a part
of the actual applications,
and thereby this
makes kind of changes
very difficult because
again, if we're
trying to innovate, improve
the platform, add new features
and fix new bugs, we have
to, in this architecture,
go through each and
every application theme
and essentially beg
them to kind of upgrade
to the latest and
greatest, which
also makes things extremely
challenging in practice for us.
And of course, enforcement
of appropriate usage
of this framework is
also quite tricky.
So I suppose the question here
is, is there a middle ground?
Between the centralized
solution that we had
and the kind of more distributed
solution using frameworks
where we don't have the
centralized kind of problems
going on, is there
something that would give us
the best of both worlds?
And without the problems
that come with these two
kind of architectural patterns?
And essentially, the
answer to the question
presented itself with the
introduction, or at least
the introduction for us,
to the sidecar pattern.
So when we learned about
this particular pattern,
we were extremely excited,
because this was--
we immediately recognized
that this pattern
would be essentially
the next step in kind
of evolving our overall
architecture, especially
as a platform theme.
And the idea is pretty simple.
We essentially take whatever
the microservices framework was
doing or that centralized
kind of solution and we
extract that into
a sidecar proxy.
And a sidecar proxy would
facilitate the same use cases
and requirements, but no
longer be actually hardcoded
in the application
while still maintaining
that decentralized
kind of characteristic.
And so this solution
is beautiful
because it's transparent.
It's fully polyglot.
We only have to
implement it once.
We don't need to port it to
all of the different technology
stacks.
It's fully decentralized.
And it's also efficient
because we're not
adding those kind of multiple
remote hops on the network.
So very excited to start
implementing this thing.
And as we start
thinking about, OK,
how do we get sidecars onto
each and every workload
that we're running, the
first thing you realize
is, well, obviously
somehow we'll
have to kind of
manage and maintain
the operational semantics
of each and every sidiecar
that we have in
our architecture.
So we need to kind of be
able to dynamically configure
these things and
change how they behave
as the conditions of our
overall system are changing.
And so obviously we need
some type of control plane
to manage all of this.
And so this is kind
of the architecture
or the architecture
idea that we landed on.
And thus far, I've
only shown you
kind of general patterns
and boxes and arrows.
I suppose the big
question now is, OK,
how do we go about
actually implementing this?
What are the ready
kind of solutions
that we could employ to get
some architecture like this
to kind of work for us?
And so we're actually in a
very luxury type of position
because in this
day and age, there
are many different types
of service measures
that one could kind of choose
from to kind of realize
this particular architecture.
Now, for us, since we were
very early to the game
with this particular
kind of solution,
we essentially adopted
the first service mesh
that that came out, at
least that we knew of,
and that was Linkerd.
So Linkerd kind of brought
about this kind of revolution
in thinking with regards to
handling platform concerns
in a sidecar.
And we were very
quick to kind start
to think about how do we bring
it into our architecture, what
do we need to do to make
this thing a reality?
And so us being Walmart,
obviously we're not a startup.
We can't just take
something that is ready
and just think it's just
going to work for us.
We need to integrate
it into a larger
pre-existing architecture.
And so we already had systems
for service registration
and identity management,
for cloud configuration,
and a system for
telemetry and alerting
and you name it,
which was essentially
our kind of de
facto control plane.
And the beautiful
thing about Linkerd
is the fact that
it's quite modular
and we could kind of extend
it and implement plugins.
So that's what we did.
We implemented a whole
bunch of plugins, integrated
into our existing ecosystem in
the preexisting architecture.
And we essentially hit
the ground running.
Now, the other
interesting thing is
that we were also able to
implement a policy engine,
or actually we ported the
existing policy engine
that we also had in
the previous solutions
and now had that execute
in linkerd directly
in the sidecar.
So we even had a transparent
backward compatible solution
for this kind of next
generation architecture.
Now again, us being
Walmart and having
this kind of diverse landscape
of technologies and use cases
and requirements
and immense scale,
there's always room
for different solutions
to co-exist.
And so at this point,
we're also thinking
about going forward
with adopting
Istio as a service mesh.
And Istio is actually quite
beautiful, as well-- very
modular, and we're doing
the same kind of exercise
with integrating
it into our kind
of preexisting architecture.
And what you see
here on the picture
doesn't really depict
the integrations
that we've done
because I don't really
have enough time to kind of
go into detail about that.
So feel free to kind of reach
out to me after the talk.
But essentially, you'll notice
of a pretty much default
setup with Istio, minus a
couple of subtle differences.
So for one, we're not
leveraging the egress gateway
at this point.
We've kind of offloaded its
concerns onto the sidecars
directly.
And the other thing
is that we decided
not to use the policy mixer,
which essentially means
that we're not leveraging
the native policy enforcement
that Istio provides.
And that's for good reason,
because we have our own policy
engine.
And we need to be backward
compatible, once again,
with all of this
preexisting architecture.
And so therefore, we essentially
started off, actually,
with implementing an
external mixer adapter.
But since our policies are
not really properly cacheable,
doing remote policy
enforcement is quite expensive.
And the latency
numbers weren't really
where we wanted them to be.
However, Istio and Envoy we
have this kind of awesome thing
where essentially there's
some type of JIT compiler
inside of Envoy.
So you can kind of send
Lua scripts to Envoy,
and then thereby have
it kind of execute
any additional
semantics that you want.
And so what we ended
up doing is kind
of porting our existing
policy engine to Lua
and essentially
leveraging that to get
the same kind of transparent
backward compatible setup,
but now with this Istio.
So there's that.
So now if there's
one thing I'd like
you to take away from at least
my part of this particular talk
is the fact that as we've
kind of been evolving
our architecture and making
steps into kind of introducing
new patterns and everything,
essentially the commonality is
that with every
improvement we make,
we're taking an old set of
problems and solving them,
but thereby introducing a
brand new set of problems.
And so we're under no
illusion that the service mesh
is some type of silver
bullet that solves
all problems for ages to come.
Clearly, there will
be a brand new set
of challenges which will take
things to the next level.
Now, what are those
next set-- what
is that next set of challenges?
I have some ideas.
I don't know exactly yet.
Perhaps I'll have
an answer next year.
But we're very excited with
this kind of new evolution,
especially as a platform theme.
So with that, I will thank
you for your attention.
And please give a warm
welcome to Prajakta.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
thank you, Georgi.
And I think Georgi
said it really well.
We have to make sure that we
solve the challenges that you
face as you bring in all
of these new technologies.
So Georgi, let me tell you
about a set of challenges
I keep hearing from
Google Cloud customers.
And that's, like
Georgi mentioned,
a very nice pattern on how
they went to the service mesh.
Similarly, we have
questions from customers
that how do I go
and bring service
mesh into my Brownfield?
Or how do I go and containerize
into my existing Brownfield
deployment?
Because if you really
think of the customer,
they don't really care
about service mesh.
They're not really
caring about containers.
What they're really asking
for is infrastructure and data
scalability.
They want smaller independent
development teams.
They want to ship faster.
And they want to keep or deploy
services wherever they want.
But they want to manage
all of these uniformly.
And they definitely don't want
to build a services management
infrastructure or manage it.
And they want to migrate
from their starting point
at their pace.
So there are four
transformational technologies
that I keep hearing
customers ask
on how to bring into their
Brownfield-- microservices,
containerization, service
mesh, and serverless.
Have several different patterns.
I'm going to talk about
one or two patterns
on how customers do this.
But one frequent question I
hear is, should I mesh first
or should I containerize first?
And I want to describe
two different approaches.
These are inspired by our
two real world customers
on how they actually
did it or how
they're thinking of doing it.
Let's talk about
customer A. Now,
their strategy is to mesh
first and then containerize.
Why is that?
So one thing I want to actually
say before even we deep
dive into customer
A is that there
is a very common misconception
that service mesh is
for containerized services.
And actually, that's not true.
So let's look at our customer A.
This is a pretty big customer.
They started their journey to
Google Cloud a few years back.
And they had one big monolith.
And then they chopped it up.
So it went to 20 microservices.
Then they got it to Google Cloud
and they chopped it up further.
They got 80 microservices.
They were able to get
the agility that you
get with microservices.
But there's a problem, too.
Because they went
from managing one
monolith to going and
managing hundreds of services.
And so in their set of
goals, getting a way
to go manage these
seamlessly, easily, uniformly
was much higher than going
and containerizing them first.
And so they said, we will go
and adopt the service mesh first
and then we will containerize.
And obviously, if
you think of it,
if you went and
containerized a monolith,
you probably wouldn't
get much, anyways.
So what was their blueprint?
What did they do?
The starting point was a
VM-based set of services.
Obviously this is just
a very small subset
of what services they ran.
Then they added
the sidecar proxy
to their VM-based services.
They also deployed an ingress.
Now, ingress is a very
critical part of service mesh,
because that is where you
are guarding the entry
point to your mesh.
And you want it to
provide DDoS defense.
You want it to be very
robust because that
is where a lot of your external
traffic comes and hits.
And so they had an
ingress to provide
a secure and programmable
entry point to their mesh.
And then they layered in the
service mesh control plane.
And then they move some of their
services from VMs to containers
and they lived
happily ever after.
At this point, you should
be asking me, but how?
So let's take a
step back and let's
see how they actually did it.
Now, every customer has
a strategy, generally,
when they do this type of
transition or transformation.
And one of the strategies
that customer A had
was to go with managed
services wherever possible.
And this was simply
so that they could
make the move faster without
having the expertise in-house
to go manage the infrastructure
or even build it.
So they had four
main considerations.
What do I go and use for
container management?
What do I do with the
service mesh control plane?
Where do I get that
as a managed service?
Where do I get an
Envoy image from?
And then who manages
the Envoy lifecycle?
Because that's one of
the frequent questions
we get, as well.
So here is the
approach they took.
Essentially for
container orchestration
they use GKE, which is
Google Kubernetes Engine.
For the service mesh
traffic control plane,
they are planning to use
Traffic Director, which
just went beta yesterday.
For the opinionated
and certified image,
they used an image from Tetrate.
And then for the Envoy
lifecycle management,
they plan to use a
Tetrate solution, as well,
and we'll talk about it shortly.
So I'm not going to
deep dive a lot into GKE
because there are several
excellent docs on it.
I highly recommend
watching them.
But let's go to
Traffic Director.
So what exactly is
Traffic Director?
If you really think of
adopting the service mesh,
one is the transformation
inside your organization
as Georgi spoke about.
And then the second
part of it is also
having pieces in the control
plane that are delivered to you
as a service.
And so that's why
yesterday in Urs's keynote
we launched Traffic Director.
It's our new GCP-managed
service for the service mesh.
And there's also detailed
talk on Traffic Director
from yesterday.
So here is what it does.
First of all, imagine
that you have your data
plane that's comprised of your
VM or container-based services.
You go and inject your
Envoy proxies in there
and then the Traffic
Director becomes
the control plane for it.
It will give you
global load balancing.
It'll offload the
health checking
from your Envoy instances.
It'll also give you a
traffic driven auto scaling.
It will also give you a bunch
of traffic control capabilities.
And if you already use Envoy
you're familiar with those--
canaries, traffic splitting,
traffic steering, metering,
circuit breaking, and so on.
And the nice part
is it's GCP managed.
So you will get a production
grid as a layer [INAUDIBLE]..
So it takes a lot of the toil
out of going and managing
this stuff.
One of the key things
that we emphasized
when we built this out is it has
to work for VMs and containers
out of the box.
So if you actually look
at my example here,
the first service is
essentially self managed Docker.
The second one is
a VM-based service.
And then the third one is a
Kubernetes engine service.
So it is able to manage
all of these heterogeneous
environments very seamlessly.
And then you can have things
like deploying your instances
anywhere.
That's what you get out of
the global load balancer.
And what that really means--
so why is global load
balancing important?
The reason it is important
is that, first of all,
you don't need to configure
anything to make that happen.
All you do is create a
service, put your instances
in whichever part of GCP
regions that makes sense for you
or where your users are.
And then you turn
on Traffic Director.
And what it will do is that if
your service in region-- let's
say all of the instances
for a service go down.
When the traffic is
coming to that region,
it will seamlessly redirect it
or overflow to another region.
And you don't need
any configuration
to make that happen.
That's implicitly built in
into the Traffic Director.
There's another very
interesting reason
I brought up Traffic
Director in this talk, which
is how do you go
make the transition
from a VM-based
service to containers?
There is a construct
called network endpoint
groups, which I'll talk about.
So imagine initially your
service was sitting in the VM
and we have what is called
managed instance group.
That's where you specify
all your VM endpoints
and then your service
is essentially
instantiated into that.
Now, imagine you wanted to
containerize that service.
There's a construct called
network endpoint groups.
And so you go create a
service, service 1 prime.
And you add all of the container
endpoints inside a network
endpoint group.
The network endpoint
groups lets you see
those individual containers.
And so you can load
balance to them.
You can do traffic control
to them individually.
And so now what you do
is you have a service--
the same version of the service,
which is in VM instances,
and another one which is
sitting in containers.
And so you sent traffic to both.
You have control
knobs so you can
say 99% goes here, 1% goes
here, and so on and so forth.
Once you do that, then
what you do is you
start draining your
VM based service.
So slowly, slowly, slowly,
you start shifting the traffic
to your containers.
And then eventually
what you can do
is you can drain away
your VM-based service.
And you can do all of
this without disruption,
which is why it's really huge
from the point of migrating
a given service from
VMs to containers.
And then this will
get even easier
because we have a plan to
support both a managed instance
group and a network endpoint
group behind the same service.
And so you don't even need
to create another service.
You just create a
network endpoint group
and then slowly
migrate your traffic
from their managed instance
group to a network endpoint
group.
So it just gives
you a very easy way
to go from VMs to containers
for a given service.
The second part of the problem
is like how do we go and manage
the Envoy lifecycle.
This is a question
I get asked often.
And I wanted to invite Dhi
from Tetrate to talk about some
of the solutions they
have in this space.
DHI AURRAHMAN: Hello, everyone.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Dhi from Tetrate.
I'm a software
engineer at Tetrate.
I'm very lucky to be here.
Thank you, Prajakta.
So the question is how we do
the Envoy lifecycle management.
So the challenges with
Envoy lifecycle management
will be where do we
get the Envoy binaries?
I mean, getting the trusted
and updated build of Envoy
is not easy.
I mean, building yourselves
probably will be a torture.
And then it would be another
one, integrated vulnerability
check and scanning,
and how if there
is a fix on upstream,
how you get it.
And then how do you exactly do
it, that upgrading your Envoy?
So here at Tetrate, we
do this some tooling
that do the initialization
and do the continuous stack
in your infrastructure.
And we do this out of the
attack, for every attack,
and so on and so forth.
And we also offer
how to upgrade that.
So here, this is the GetEnvoy.
GetEnvoy is one of our
products that we launched.
It is still in preview,
but we will do this
build distribution of Envoy.
It is trusted.
It is certified.
And there is there will
be a mechanism on how
to upgrade Envoy and also how
we do the integrated scanning
for patching the Envoy.
OK, so GetEnvoy by
Tetrate, Tetrate
will open the access of
the build pipeline itself.
It will be there for public.
And we committed to
work with the community,
bringing tested Envoy build
with low costs in your site.
So we also work hard to
integrate that [INAUDIBLE]
patching to upstream.
So we also have additional
protocol support
if you need it.
And we have full
attention support
from maintenance inside Tetrate.
So we have one senior maintainer
in Tetrate and for proxy
and another maintainer.
So this is a case when you
do the vulnerability scanning
synthetic attack to do
[INAUDIBLE] scanning.
One of this is a
synthetic attack.
So basically, you
do checking on--
so we have Envoy
built in our local--
in your environment.
And then we do the
synthetic attack on that.
And we check if it
is vulnerable or not.
So this kind of a mechanism
will be integrated.
It can be standalone
it or it can be
integrated to your environment.
So more than that, we also
offer Envoy customization
because probably you
need that [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is--
Envoy at its core is extensible.
You can basically write
your very own extension.
In fact, this
extensibility really
drives the adoption of Envoy.
This is an invitation for
you to contribute to Envoy.
You can check out Envoy
on how to stand Envoy.
So this is the
integration with--
well, when you get the
Envoy from someone else,
a third party like Tetrate,
probably you want to ask,
is it compatible with any
control plane out there?
So we do this integration
with Google's Traffic Director
and Apache SkyWalking
for observability.
So we have front end running in
a VM pointing to user service.
At first, the user
service points
to profile service
that runs on VM.
And then after
that, we gradually
program Traffic Director to
point to the profile service
two on Kubernetes.
So as Prajakta
[INAUDIBLE] to you
that we will drain
the traffic from VM
to Kubernetes by programming
the Traffic Director.
So this is a video of the demo.
So first we have two
different services running
deployed in Kubernetes and VM.
And then we gradually apply the
rules to the Traffic Director
so we can move from
VM to Kubernetes.
So as you see that
here, once we implement
the policy, the routing,
from VM to Kubernetes,
we will see changes in the UI.
So let's just wait on--
OK, so as you see that when
we move the traffic from VM
to Kubernetes, it would
show a fix on the UI.
It's 50/50 traffic.
So I think that's all for me.
I'll give it back to Prajakta.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Thank you, Dhi.
And I think if you
didn't see the hearts,
they were changing
between white and red.
And so that was the 50/50
that was happening in there.
So coming back to-- so
we spoke about customary,
and Dhi showed us also how
to go inject your Envoys.
And there's a bunch of
capabilities they provide.
But then there's a different
type of customer, too.
So let's talk about
customer B. This
is a customer based out of APAC.
And they had a
different set of goals,
which was let's containerize
first, and then we will mesh.
So how did they do it?
It seems like the common
theme is a monolith on prem.
I need to add some
more blueprints where
that's not always the case.
But even this customer had
a monolith that sat on prem.
And they said we need
to move to the cloud.
While they move to
the cloud, we also
want to do some refactoring.
And then we want to make sure
that as our services move
to cloud, they are
more and more modern.
And so that was their goal.
Now, what is the strategy
that they deployed?
The first thing that
they did actually
is not much, in that they
left the monolith on prem.
Then they took Google's
global load balancer
and then they put a set of API
gateway instances behind that.
And as you can see, each of
these has a different purpose.
So there's TLS termination,
DDoS defense that they got out
of the global load balancer.
The API gateway obviously
did API-level routing.
We have several
products like Apigee,
as well, that you can use.
Then you have, as
you notice, they
wanted to do everything in a
way that their services got
containerized as
they moved to cloud.
So you can see everything
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
Obviously, nothing
has moved there yet.
And then you have
the monolith on prem.
And simply the traffic is coming
in through the global load
balancer through
your API gateway
and getting routed to on prem.
So again, no disruption
till this point of time.
Next, what they did is they
took a chunk of a service out
of the monolith-- you
can see service A--
and then they put it on prem.
When they moved it,
they containerized it.
So when it was instantiated
in Google Cloud,
it was a containerized
service that
was managed with GKE or
Google Kubernetes engine.
Similarly, they got
another service piece.
So you can see that the
monolith has started to shrink,
and then they got it
into Google Cloud.
That's your service B.
And for many of
the services, they
were able to rewrite the
services to use GRPC.
So in the event where
you can do rewrites,
I would highly recommend looking
at GRPC as your transport
interface.
And when not, you can continue
to use your HTTP and so
on and so forth, as well.
Now, once they did that,
there was some systems that--
or some services that
would never move to GCP.
An example of this
was a payment service.
And they shared
this payment service
between various deployments,
so they didn't want
to move it to Google Cloud.
But they still wanted all of the
modernization for that service.
So what they did
is they chunked out
that service, put
it on prem-- that's
what you see what service
C. And then what they did
is they wanted to
manage it using
the same primitives as they
do with GKE and Google Cloud.
So they brought in GKE On Prem.
And that is what they used
to manage this service now,
which is sitting on prem.
But the primitives are same.
GKE and Google
Cloud, GKE On Prem,
and then they don't have to
relearn two new primitives
in each case.
Now, obviously, one service
sits in Google Cloud.
Another sits on prem.
They have to communicate.
So now you need service
to service communication.
And that is what necessitated
a look at the service
mesh and then some of these
technologies about service
to service communication.
So what they did is they first
injected the Envoy proxies--
you can see on service
B and service C.
And then they manage
that with Istio on prem.
And then they have an
Istio control plane
running in GCP, as well.
At this point of
time, most people
want to get out of running
the control planes themselves.
And so now with Traffic
Director in GCP site,
they are going to manage
the traffic control
plane using Traffic Director.
And then for the
rest of the pieces,
they'll continue
to leverage Istio.
And in the future, once
we support a hybrid model
where Traffic Director can
manage instances on prem,
then they will do the
same thing for the Istio.
And then the Istio that is on
prem will remain as a fallback.
So in case Traffic
Director can't
communicate with instances,
it will fall back.
If you really think of it,
the next big innovation
or the next big--
I wouldn't call it a challenge.
I think it's an opportunity
for innovation--
is around federation of all
of these control planes.
And so you will see a lot of
conversations around this.
But this is essentially the
thing that they deployed.
And so if we had to
summarize the steps,
this is what it looks like.
So they went from a monolith--
and if you just go 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, those are
the steps that they
took to get to a
modern architecture.
So in all of this,
I know we spoke
about a bunch of solutions.
We had Georgi describe
how Walmart does it.
They describe some of the
solutions from Tetrate.
We also have a bunch of
solutions in Google Cloud.
And one of the questions I
often get asked by customers is,
should we use Google
Cloud products?
Because they are best of breed,
sure, but do they lock us in?
And it's a very frequent
question that I get.
And my question
always back to them
is, what if you could get both?
You get best-of-breed products,
but there's also no lock in.
And the key to
making that happen
is essentially the
open interfaces.
So we'll talk a little
bit more about that.
But the first thing--
so let's take a look
at the migration tools.
Here, there is no lock in,
because you're essentially
using these to do possibly
a one time migration.
I don't know how many of
you attended the keynote,
but if you did, you saw the
announcement of a product
called Anthos Migrate.
And then it's at beta.
It auto migrates VMs
from on-prem into GKE.
And so that is very minimal
effort on your end to do it.
There's an excellent
talk on it, as well.
And then what that means
is when you use-- and it's
very holistic in its approach.
So you can see it does
discovery, migration planning.
There's a whole set
of steps that it
does to get your VMs
into GKE in Google Cloud.
And so what that means is
your own folks can actually
take their time and focus on
managing your applications
without really having to worry
about how to do the migration
and so on and so forth.
Now, once you've migrated--
or even when you're in GCP--
the question is, what are
the tools you should use
and where should you
worry about lock in?
So the answer is, wherever you
find an open interface, that
is where you don't have
to worry about lock-in,
because if you don't
like something,
you can swap it out as long
as the interface is open.
And I'll give you an example.
Let's say as a starting point,
you are our load balancing
customers.
You don't really care
about the service mesh.
You don't really care about
Traffic Director initially.
So you're looking for
another flavor of L7 or LB,
or something like that.
And then what you do is imagine
that you suddenly now said,
I want to go and modernize
my load balancing.
And so I want to go look
at the service mesh.
So there is a huge bunch
of customers who start off
as load balancing
customers and then go on
to become service
mesh customers.
And in there, one of the nice
things about Traffic Director
is when it speaks
to the Envoy, it
uses XDS APIs, which is
what the open interface used
for any service mesh control
plane that talks to Envoys.
And so if you don't like Traffic
Director, you can swap it out.
And it doesn't even have to
be Envoy in your data plane,
because as long as that
proxy supports XDS,
you could bring your own proxy.
You could go customize
Envoy, as long as you
preserve that open interface.
And so that's the
track we are taking
to ensure that there's no lock
in, while at the same time,
we do want to take away the
toil of managing these control
planes.
So actually, there's
another very interesting set
of customers who are like, I
want all of this modernization
without having to worry about
Traffic Director or Envoy.
And they're like, OK.
We have a service setting
which just cannot--
I cannot go inject
an Envoy in there.
So what do I go to there?
And so that is why we created
another flavor called L7 ILB.
So it looks like any other
load balancer to you.
And so what you would do is you
would get all of the benefits
that you get from traffic
control and other primitives
from [INAUDIBLE] Envoy,
but you don't necessarily
need to even worry about
a control plane or a data
plane or running Envoys.
It just looks like any other
[INAUDIBLE] proxy to you.
And you take it and you put
it in front of your services.
What it really looks like
under the hood is this.
So it is Traffic Director which
is managing a pool of Envoys
for you, but it's
abstracting all of this out
and just making it look like
any [INAUDIBLE] proxy to you.
So it's which
technologies you adopt
and which sequence is a
function of the skill set
that you have in your folks,
or what your goals are,
or what is the strategy
you want to start
with, what other considerations
do you have in terms of cost,
time, and so on?
And once you've
nailed that down,
then it gets easier to
start picking one or more
of these technologies.
There's another set of
customers who actually is not
from the load balancing pool.
Now, they come in from the
point of view of saying,
I have these multi
cloud services,
or I have microservices.
And I want to go and
consistently and uniformly
manage them.
And so they are probably
already GKE customers,
or they may be looking at GKE.
Several of these
might have used Envoy
in various forms and shapes.
Many of them may be open
source to your users.
And so that is where,
again, you have
a whole slew of options in
here, ranging from open source
to Google Manage.
And the key in
each of these-- so
like whether you self manage
Kubernetes or whether use a GKE
or whether you use
GKE on prem, it's
the same set of APIs
and primitives, which
means you don't get locked in.
You can switch
between each of these.
Similarly, if you
use Traffic Director
or you use Istio
to talk to Envoy,
or you have your home grown
control plane that talks xDSv2,
you don't get locked in,
because you have the capability
to go and switch, because
the APIs and the interfaces
are open.
And then there's
another one which
I think we don't talk about
enough, which is GRPC.
If you have services
that are using HTTP, HTTP
1.1, et cetera, and you want to
bring in HTTP 2 as an example,
then you would--
you bring in HTTP 2,
you would bring in
GRPC, and so on.
If you have services
that you cannot rewrite,
then you can keep it as a goal
and save it up for your phase
2.
Then the next thing
which I often get
asked-- so all of these.
But there is a set
of people who don't
want to see any infrastructure
at all, whether it's
service management
infrastructure, whether it's
container orchestration,
and so on.
And that is where, really, if
you were there yesterday or day
before, you heard
about Cloud Run,
that's essentially serverless.
And again, the same question.
Like, do we get locked
into your solutions?
And the answer is no,
because if you look at it,
first there's Cloud Run.
So it's fully managed.
You deploy your workloads.
You don't see the cluster.
It's fully managed
service for you.
But then I have a GKE cluster.
So then you go and
use Cloud Run on GKE.
And then what that
lets you do is
you run the serverless side
by side your container,
so your existing workloads.
And then it runs seamlessly.
But then a lot of you also have
on prem or other deployments
of Kubernetes.
And then you are like,
what about Cloud Run there?
And so that's what
Knative lets you do.
I don't know how many of you
attended all of these talks.
But they're excellent talks that
go through these three options.
And the key is, again, the same.
You're using the same tooling,
the same APIs across the board
and wherever you're
on Kubernetes.
And then you get
the same primitives
without having to relearn.
And I think that is
the broader theme
I want you to take away from
a lot of these services that
are being built.
So when we say we build
tools for multi cloud,
a very key aspect
of it is it has
to support these open
interfaces, which
brings me back to the end.
So we spoke about
Walmart's journey.
We spoke about customer A,
who first meshed and then
containerized.
And then we spoke
about customer B
who actually first
containerized and then meshed.
And imagine that there are three
or more other patterns where
they're not necessarily
starting from monoliths.
In fact, we have
a talk today where
we talk about how
service measure's equally
applicable to Telco workloads.
So one of the key things
about these technologies
is, they don't really
make assumptions
about whether it's VMs,
containers, whether it
runs in Google or elsewhere.
Like, these are very
good abstractions
from that point of view.
And so how to use them and
when to use them actually
boils down to having a plan.
And here are the
typical steps that
are common across these
five or six blueprints.
So when you start your
journey to going and migrating
your own workloads,
or even bringing
all of these technologies
to brownfield,
you have to start
with your goals.
Like, what are your goals?
Why is it that you
want to bring in?
And hopefully the answer is
not just because they are cool,
because all of these are
extremely cool technologies.
But there has to be
some business goal
or there has to be something
around agility or some problem
that it solves for you.
And that is the crux
of it, honestly.
Once you've identified
that, then you
can map to one of
these strategies.
We'll have a lot
more papers that
go out that describe each
of these in detail and more.
And so once you've
identified your strategy,
then the strategy will
let you choose tools.
And that will depend on what
is the kind of tool you want?
Like, I would say the table
stakes is open interfaces.
Like, look for open
interfaces because then you
can change your mind.
You can swap things out
and bring in new tools.
And this could be
Google Cloud tools.
These could be
third party tools.
Often, we have a lot
of complementary tools
for the problems that you
face and we don't necessarily
have a solution.
So identify your
services and tools.
Make sure you've done your
due diligence on them.
Once you've done that, most of
the success stories that we see
are customers who have
had an MVP use case, which
means that there's
a set of services
they identified and then
they execute the strategy
with those small
set of services.
And then once they
see success, they
will go and optimize,
because obviously there
are learnings from their
first phase of execution.
And then they'll optimize
and it's rinse repeat.
And in all of these,
one of the critical bits
is essentially to automate,
automate, automate.
I can't stress that enough.
But again, the success
stories of making these things
repeatable, easy to
manage, is that you
bring in the CI/CD pipelines.
We have customers who manage--
like, code in CI/CD pipelines.
And it just makes their
lives that much easier.
So I know it was a bit
of a whirlwind tour,
but we hope we gave
you at least a flavor
of the various
strategies you can
use to bring in service
mesh, containers,
and modern technologies
into your brownfield.
So with that, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]